Bienvenidos a este programa especial de
medio ambiente yo soy María Clara calle
2022 fue un año particular porque
corroboró la emergencia climática que
enfrenta el planeta y el poco tiempo que
nos queda para revertirlo así lo
evidenciaron los extremos del clima que
se vieron con las inundaciones en
Pakistán las olas de calor en buena
parte del mundo y la hambruna que
enfrenta el cuerno de África desde la
era Industrial los humanos comenzamos a
calentar la tierra a un ritmo que no se
veía hace cientos de miles de años la
NASA recopiló las imágenes de la
temperatura terrestre desde 1800 hasta
el año 2019 con capturas cada cinco años
y esto nos permite ver cómo vivimos en
un planeta que se hace cada vez más
caliente es mayor medida por los gases
de efecto invernadero como los que
producen los combustibles fósiles el
calentamiento se evidencia especialmente
al comparar la primera y la última
imagen capturada por los estudios
espaciales
y ese calentamiento es el que
prometieron limitar más de 190 países
con el acuerdo de París de 2015 los
gobiernos pusieron la meta que la
temperatura no aumente más de dos grados
Celsius en comparación con los niveles
preindustriales y en el mejor de los
casos poner el límite en 1,5 grados La
pregunta es qué tan lejos estamos el
programa de la ONU para el medio
ambiente dice que con las políticas
ambientales actuales vamos rumbo a subir
dos coma ocho grados para finales de
siglo y aún así no hay metas más
ambiciosas en France 24 hablamos con
Edwin Castellanos uno de los autores del
último reporte del panel
intergubernamental de expertos en cambio
climático el ipcc él cree que el 1,5
sigue vivo pero advierte que esto
requiere una reducción drástica de gases
contaminantes
desafortunadamente en la última década
del 2000 al 2019
las emisiones de estos gases han sido
las más altas que hemos tenido en toda
la historia de la humanidad
Eso quiere decir que vamos en una ruta
de un aumento de temperatura mucho mayor
a lo que se acordó en el acuerdo de
París de hecho la temperatura de uno
punto cinco grados si seguimos con las
tendencias actuales podría alcanzarse
tan rápido como el año 2030 las
emisiones han estado subiendo
constantemente a pesar de que se tiene
una la la la la convención Marco que
está buscando reducir esas emisiones el
ipcc indica que las emisiones deberían
de alcanzar un máximo en el 2025 empezar
a bajar y tener una reducción del 43% de
las emisiones actuales para el 2030 Esto
es para lograr mantenernos a esa
temperatura Esto entonces muestra que sí
se puede lograr el uno punto cinco pero
con reducciones drásticas de emisiones
El problema es que de ese uno coma cinco
ya alcanza grados Celsius Y en lugar de
reducir los gases de efecto invernadero
la humanidad los está aumentando los
tres principales contaminantes que son
el dióxido de carbono el metano y el
óxido nitroso alcanzaron sus máximos
históricos en 2021 según la Organización
meteorológica Mundial el ipcc estima que
los veranos serán más secos y más
prolongados por ejemplo en el
Mediterráneo África y en el oeste de
América del Norte una advertencia de
científica que se sintió con fuerza con
las olas de calor
Un verano con los meses más calurosos de
la historia eso fue lo que vivió Europa
en 2022 la temporada comenzó con un mayo
inusual que llevó oleadas de aire
caliente del
zar Occidental al suroeste europeo eso
contribuyó a que el de este año fuera el
segundo junio más caluroso del
continente una temporada que padecieron
especialmente España Francia e Italia
con miles de incendios forestales
según copérnicos el observatorio de la
Unión Europea en julio La ola de calor
se extendió al norte y al este y por
primera vez ese que se tiene Registro un
lugar en Reino Unido collinsville superó
los 40 grados celsius y esta vez el
calor se extendió hasta mediados de
octubre afectando la agricultura y la
salud como nos lo explicó Raquel García
del WWF principalmente los impactos en
el sector agricultura por ejemplo al
aumentar las temperaturas aumentan las
sequías y esta falta de agua afecta a
los regadíos disminuyendo la
productividad de los de las cosechas y
puede provocar a futuro problemas de
abastecimiento alimentario además muchos
cultivos se tienen que desplazar a las
zonas del norte de Europa por falta de
agua en cuanto a las afecciones a la
salud se afectará sobre todo a los
colectivos más vulnerables como los
ancianos los niños o los enfermos porque
estas olas de calor pueden provocar
muertes los calores extremos también se
padecieron en China La ola del 13 de
junio al 30 de agosto no sólo fue la más
larga de todas sino que por su
intensidad fue la peor temporada de
calor en la historia del gigante
asiático desde que se tiene registro en
1961 el yang el río más largo de Asia
tuvo niveles mínimos que incluso
afectaron a las hidroeléctricas y el
otoño tampoco fue muy distinto al
europeo entre septiembre y noviembre la
temperatura media fue casi un grado
superior al del mismo periodo del resto
de los años analizados
hacía demasiado calor para conciliar el
sueño todas las noches y me despertaba
por el calor excesivo todas las mañanas
a limitar el suministro eléctrico
llevaron a la ciudad a la oscuridad
donde Antes había luces de neón por
todas partes las luces innecesarias se
apagaron principalmente en lugares como
los supermercados
Estados Unidos tuvo un septiembre
similar a principios del mes una cúpula
de calor se asentó en el oeste y trajo
temperaturas récord más de 60 millones
de personas estaban bajo alerta por
calor extremo y aún sin el registro
oficial de Muertos parece que se cumplió
la tendencia del servicio nacional
climático que afirma que el calor es la
mayor causa de los fallecimientos por
clima en el país superando incluso a los
huracanes el frío extremo y las
inundaciones
pero si queremos hablar de inundaciones
sin duda este daño debemos remitirnos a
Pakistán En 2022 la temporada de
monzones que se da todos los años en el
sudeste asiático fue la más dura en la
historia del país un tercio del
territorio quedó inundado lo que afectó
a 33 millones de personas que
corresponde al 15% de la población y más
de 2.000 personas murieron las
consecuencias pueden significar entre el
2 y el 5% del producto interno bruto
pakistaní la ONU estima que los daños
que son las infraestructuras físicas que
se perdieron ascienden a 14.900 millones
de dólares mientras que las pérdidas que
es el dinero que la economía dejó de
producir por las inundaciones son de más
de 15.000 millones además se necesitan
al menos 16.300 millones de dólares para
reconstruir lo perdido y prepararse para
los siguientes monzones que según las
tendencias climáticas podrían ser
incluso peores en France 24 hablamos con
el director de WWF Pakistán y explicó
que las consecuencias de las
inundaciones continúan
todavía hay cientos de miles de personas
que se desplazaron y que siguen viviendo
en las calles hubo unos pequeños alivios
hubo países que donaron y proveyeron
algunos alivios financieros pero para la
escala del problema es una tontería y lo
digo honestamente y ahora es el comienzo
de la temporada de invierno
No es solo que hayan perdido sus medios
de subsistencia es literalmente una
emergencia de salud pública porque hay
una alta cantidad de casos de malaria
reportados y el gobierno está luchando
incluso por conseguir suficientes
mosquiteros para las comunidades
Y es que los países menos desarrollados
como Pakistán la falta de dinero lleva a
que sea más difícil hacerle frente a las
pérdidas y los daños de la crisis por
eso en la cop 27 que se hizo en Egipto
este año Pakistán lideró la petición del
sur global para que las naciones
industrializadas financien un mecanismo
con este propósito y aunque se aceptó
Todavía faltan años para que comience a
funcionar según nos dijo jamathy quien
también dice que el dinero que han dado
organizaciones internacionales es
insuficiente
pero Miren la cantidad que pidió la ONU
y miren la cantidad que ha recibido
Pakistán es apenas unos cuantos millones
de dólares un país prometió 50 millones
de dólares el otro 30 millones pero
todavía muchas de esas promesas no se
han materializado creo que es muy
importante que después de este post
desastre se necesitan decisiones hay un
estudio que solicitó al Banco Mundial y
que hizo el programa de la ONU para el
desarrollo otros aliados que claramente
documenta las necesidades para la
educación la salud el transporte porque
la infraestructura como carretera
puentes hospitales escuelas en esas
áreas literalmente todo quedó aniquilado
el mundo necesita darse cuenta y
entender que la catástrofe fue sin
precedentes
creo que pueden pasar años antes de que
este fondo de pérdidas y daños comience
a operar realmente y pueda jugar el rol
que debería tener en el momento en el
que estamos hablando
de los bloques que impulsó la creación
del fondo de pérdidas y daños fueron los
países africanos en 2022 las olas de
calor pegaron tan fuerte que tuvieron la
peor sequía en 40 años en el cuerno de
África y una combinación de factores
está poniendo en riesgo la alimentación
de millones de personas la clasificación
de seguridad alimentaria del ipc estima
que 26 millones de personas están en
crisis aguda en emergencia y de ellas
más de 200.000 están en hambruna el peor
de los niveles y los tiempos secos han
empeorado la crisis por la dificultad de
encontrar agua desde Kenia John obtiene
activista para el cuerno de África y
África del este de acción contra el
hambre Nos cuenta Cuáles han sido las
consecuencias
hemos visto un incremento de casos de
malnutrición niños desnutridos en los
Centros donde recibíamos Quizás 10 niños
en un mes ahora recibimos cerca de 100 y
eso ya está trayendo una gran
consecuencia para los sistemas de salud
ahora están lidiando con un aumento de
los casos de cólera por qué porque ellos
están accediendo a agua sucia o porque
ya están tan desesperados que van por el
agua que se supone es para las vacas o
los animales Y eso es lo que están
usando para su consumo
la inseguridad alimentaria es todavía
más grave En somalia John o Tino quien
ha recurrido estos países explica porque
la situación política y de seguridad
Incluso el acceso a la comida ha sido un
problema en somalia incluso para las
organizaciones ahora estamos
esforzándonos para transportar los
alimentos para enfrentar la malnutrición
Por qué Porque hay ciertas áreas que
están siendo controladas por los
insurgentes
los padres y madres tienen que buscar
ayuda sanitaria en instalaciones en
tierras lejanas y llega la muerte Porque
si eres un niño desnutrido y tienes que
caminar 50 o 100 km para buscar salud
Eso ya te pone en una situación muy
difícil
para evitar estas catástrofes climáticas
los expertos con los que hablamos
coinciden en una solución reducir los
combustibles fósiles como el petróleo el
gas y el carbón pero el tiempo se acaba
y los países todavía no parecen estar
dispuestos a cumplir con estas demandas
con este llamado Terminamos el especial
de alguno de los eventos climáticos más
extremos del 2022 le agradezco a Manuela
Cano Pulido quien trabajó en este
programa nos vemos pronto